the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi everyone so I am I'm the other person
who teaches this class you are the
advocate for the first class I am going
to start by doing a bit of housekeeping
keeping in mind that I don't maybe some
people are going to arrive so it is your
responsibility to inform everybody else
that of what I said today just I got
some requests of clarifying what was the
requirement for this class so I'll just
go through it once so we are going to
post a set of pics 10 for 10 topics and
we are going to give like 3 or 4 choices
you can also make your own essay
whatever it is you have a chance to
write up to 10 essays but you don't need
to write that money you're going to be
graded out of the best 5 so you can
write any between 1 and 10 and if you
have one you're not going to have a very
high grade but any between 5 and 10 and
then we'll just take the best 5 okay I
think the syllabus said 7 and Bridget
said 5 so I went further
the easiest thing so that's one thing
the the syllabus also said that we might
not grade all of them but actually we
are going to grade all of them so just
you know I would suggest that you do the
first one so that you get you get some
you get used to it traditionally it has
been the case that when students can
decide how to arrange their the
deadlines they think X on T that is it
sufficient to set all the deadlines late
in the semester I can tell you by
experience that it's actually done
experts not to be such a good idea
if I were you I would kind of arrange
things to do them as many of them early
as possible so you don't get panicked by
the end that's one the other component
of the requirement for these classes is
to do the readings and so to be prepared
to to discuss to discuss in the class
one way in which we are going to ensure
that you're making you're doing the
reading is a very very short pop quizzes
once in a while it also means you have
to come to class that's part of it's not
a class that's very difficult but one
thing that it requires actually you
actually come and so we're going to have
doors at any random times very simple
two three four questions just to check
that you've actually read the thing and
today the essay the essay topic for the
first day the questions for the first
topic were already posted on Stella so
you can you already have access to them
as well as the deadline for the first
thing that's it other than that I think
I gave a version of this pill in 1474
yesterday there are two development
classes so if you're wondering which one
you should be in this one is going to be
more based on readings and discussion
and lectures and the other one is going
to be more to going to go more in the
detail of the techniques of papers and
solving the models and replicating
empirical papers etc so this one is a
better introduction and the other one is
better if you already have a fair amount
of economics and econometrics so that's
kind of the that's the trade-off
other than that obviously that teams
that we are going to be cover are going
to be pretty similar so my sense is
probably you don't want to take both at
the same time although you could think
of taking them both in sequence then you
would do 73 for 70 for a second
I don't recognize any 74 students but
you shouldn't want to take 70 473 that
would be a bit boring so you can you're
welcome to
to shop a little bit for some time and
then decide what's more appropriate
you're welcome to take bowls but I would
have warned you that there will be some
overlap in between the two that's it for
housekeeping so if you have questions
that's a good time I'm happy to answer
questions by email also but chances are
if you have a question on the logistics
a lot of people share it as well any
questions no the class has been recorded
that's for OpenCourseWare but don't
worry about saying anything embarrassing
that would be edited out I'm the only
one who and it is going to be the only
ones who are finger recording on tape
saying things embarrassing I'm assuming
if you say something extremely smart we
can keep it though so there is no danger
of if we just ignore them and hopefully
it's the idea is that if it works well
then we'll have one it will be one of
these classes that people can take on
their own down the line
anything else any questions no questions
when you speak if you at the beginning
if you at least would state your name so
that I progressively get to know who you
are
can I ask you by your name that would be
nice and otherwise we're ready to roll
so we dive in let's dive in so I am in
the video that you saw last time you saw
quite a few people who were maybe
trapped in some kind of poverty trap so
for example there was this farmer who
before he was given fertilizer had very
low in yield and because he had very low
yield didn't have much money because he
didn't have much money couldn't buy
fertilizer
therefore I continued to a very low
yield and what the
Podrick did the Millennium Village
project it is to give him the fertilizer
and the hope was that with this first
lead for fertilizer his yield would
increase by sufficient by a sufficient
amount that down the line he would be
able to buy his own fertilizer and grow
more on Mommy's and then you know
progressively maybe starts like feeding
his children better and buying them
books and all those other things you
want to think about so in that video the
the Sachs and Jolie video that we saw
last time this argument that there might
be this poverty traps keep coming over
and over again so you see it for example
in Canada story with the farmers you see
it in the schools the schools don't have
computers so the kids can not really
learn well you start putting them
putting computers and kids can run but
they will then make more money they will
then be able to buy a computer for their
schools etc Exeter so one of the thing
that we are going to do a lot of in this
class is to to spend to try to
understand when there are such poverty
traps and when in fact maybe they are no
it's not so obvious and for that we have
to understand what creates the
conditions for such poverty trap to to
amount so what I want to do today it's
going to we are going to Delhi on one
example of one particular poverty trap
and how that could work which is going
to be a the the fact that we are
physical biological bodies but what we
are going to go over at the mechanism
it's going to carry us during the entire
class we're going to have to be looking
for the same type of conditions so I'm
to start with the story of someone that
actually I met I met him some day called
back so lean back means mister mister
saline
so it has he people Indonesia I don't
really have a first name and last name
just have a name and so for example mrs.
so-and-so is EBU I would be EBU a staff
for example this guy's especially and I
met him in in a village in Indonesia in
in Java which is one of the richest part
of Indonesia this is the main island
most densely populated in the summer of
2009 2008 the summer of 2008 was you
probably for you it's already ancient
history it's before the great collapse
of the of the world economy and stuff
one of the key events at the time for
the developing countries in particular
was that the food prices were very high
there has been basically since 2005 food
prices are they have increased
enormously in the world for reason that
are not fully understood and then they
collapsed again after when the whole
economy went berserk the world economy
went away the food prices also collapsed
and they have started to increase again
part of the anger that you see now in
Egypt Tunisia etc all over the Middle
East
part of it is fueled by re increasing
the food prices which are almost
reaching the 2008 level for people in
urban area this is of course immediately
threaten the livelihood because they are
they don't produce food the device would
so as soon as the food prices increases
that immediately affected them so 2008
the summer of 2008 beginning of 2008
2007 you had this kind of food riots you
observed this kind of food riots less
nothing like the thing now in Egypt but
this content in various urban center in
urban area and generally people were
wondering what was happening with the
food prices what people have been
thinking is that there are several
factors they're responsible for the
increase of the food crisis one is there
are many more people in China and India
who are making more money
and as they are making more money not
only they eat more but more than that
they eat more meat and it turns out that
to produce thousand calories of meat you
need much more grain and to produce
thousand calories of grain that may
sound strange but it turns out that the
cow is not a very efficient way to
transform the calories from going into
calories that we eat the cow starts by
losing a lot of it etc so to produce
thousand calories of cows you need much
more than thousand calories worth of
grain so as China and India is becoming
richer and eating more meat then there
is a demand for more more grains
that's one the second thing that it
happening is beer but biofuels with the
increase in and in the world prices of
sort of fuel there is more more demand
for biofuels so entire strips of Brazil
have been covered in two ways that he's
being used for to make ethanol a third
thing is oil is actually an input into
the production of food because oil is
the very important input in the
production of fertilizer so as the price
of oil increase the price of fertilizer
increase and therefore the price of food
increases so all of these factors a
fundamental factor of fundamental forces
which explains why after the shop deep
right after the the crisis the food
prices again started to increase so
that's sort of the backdrop of my visit
to to this village in Indonesia and I
met and met this guy and he was all
alone he had a small small dingy dingy
little house and he was a bit depressed
oh very depressed and why was he
depressed well he was depressed because
he was all alone at home and he was all
alone at home because his his wife had
gone to the city to start working as a
mid his
[Music]
some his oldest son had also done to the
city to start working as an apprentice
apprentice and on a construction site
and the two young kids were with the
compound so he was all alone he didn't
have anything in his house I didn't do a
lot much and he wasn't happy so the
question is how why did that happen why
was he not working and what he explained
to me is that he was not working because
he didn't have a job and he didn't have
a job because when the food price is
when the fertilizer prices in queens the
farmers that used to employ him used to
decided that they they had to do
something to cut costs they weren't very
sure whether they were going to be able
to sell their output and they were
facing those increasing in expenditure
so decided they had to cut cut cut cost
and so they could have done one of two
things what could they have done
right cut wages or they could have cut
the number of people who work for them
so of course if they had cut wages he
still would have a job but instead they
cut employment and why did they cut
employment rather than cut wages well
his theory was that if they had kept
wages he would his wages would have been
so low that it would not have been able
to buy enough food especially as the
food prices were rising at the same time
he was with the equivalent of one day
off of wage that would have been too
little to sustain himself to be strong
enough to actually work for a whole day
so seeing that the employer instead of
cutting the wage and therefore making
him unable to work then you give a wage
of someone let's say thousand rupiah's
doesn't whoopi it is not enough to get
to get yourself energetic for a full day
of work so you spend your thousand
rupiah's but the person can't feed
himself for their [ __ ] you get nothing
out of him so there is no point
back up but that's a reason why the
farmer that he used
right so what you're asking is whether
that's fine without that it's a maybe
it's a plausible theory but is there any
any truth to it we're going to spend a
fair amount of of time on this very
question not on Tuesday but on starting
Thursday what a in terms of the
empirical truth of these theories in
terms of the in terms of the biological
soundness of it it sounds that it sounds
plausible a priori that you need to
start with a certain number of calories
just to get going right your body needs
may be thousand calories just to survive
so the first thousand calories that
you're consuming are not very useful to
you to help you to actually stop
exercising then once you are alive the
next calories will start being useful so
that's the so in a pie or maybe there
was some plausibility to this theory
that's only what is theory so that means
that he he does his job so I couldn't do
much of anything he was not doing
nothing otherwise I would not have met
him he would be dead but he was doing
things that was not taking too much
effort for him for example he was
sitting on next to a the bank of a lake
and he was fishing he was getting a
little bit of rice from the government
program he was getting a little bit of
milk from his father but basically he
was not really living a full life was
sort of surviving and that so at the
heart of his theory and I think your
question of whether this is true or not
is an interest very interesting question
which certainly came to my mind when I
was talking to him but at the heart of
his theory was this like purely
biological mechanism and then on top of
this biological mechanism other thing
sort of capped up which is one is the
fact that he was not doing any
thing and that his kids were gone that
made him depressed so then it gave him
very low energy to actually do anything
so even if his theory was wrong it's not
of became trapped in a productive hub
that may have been more of a
psychological one because he was there
sitting all alone hurt unable to do
anything thinking that he was worthless
therefore in some sense becoming
worthless yeah although part of his
story is that create that where we start
seeing other bits of poverty table for
example what happened with his kid so
the kid who who had to drop out of
school to start working as a
construction worker was actually a
bright kid so that's another place where
this is you see now intergenerational
poverty trap where because the parents
are poor the kid get has to drop out of
school because he has to go to work and
therefore himself will probably make
less money down the line and that's
another thing where we have to ask
exactly the same question you were
asking before how plausible it how is it
an isolated example or is it something
that we that is generalized that it's
actually something like the inability to
work for the parents or the lack of
income that creates this that Fox's kids
to stay out of school that food as
always I've got an implication that's
another kind of place where we can find
potential your poverty table where the
kid got some schools he got a few years
of school but maybe not enough for it to
be sufficient for him to actually get a
good job down the line so and for
himself he couldn't work as a
construction worker because he was too
too weak for the basic jobs which
require some strength and - and skills
for the better jobs and too old to be an
apprentice like like his kids he was
kind of chopped so
what else is happening in his story that
you know would you would think why why
did they have to even if even if we
accept the biological mechanism which I
want to go back into in detail in a
moment something else could have
happened so for example instead of if
we're thinking that he's being out of a
job is is a temporary phenomenon maybe
you could have gotten a loan to sustain
his family so that the kid could
actually stay at least stay in school
until the time until the time for him is
to graduate then at least you wouldn't
have that intergenerational Club so so
that's another so at the heart of it we
have that biological phenomenon and an
other thing sort of creeping that
maintains his that maintain that
maintaining in this position that
creates the Bharati Parata table so what
I want to do now is to is to go through
the biological story in detail and then
we are going to see how to how the other
thing kind of add up creep in and and
create that's that trap so let's go to
the biology cat poverty trap I should
say that it's one of the most ancient
idea in economics very old idea did from
the at least from the 1950s and this is
this is all this is an old idea exactly
in this form of the of the biology so
the idea is that your first the first
few calories that you get to consume are
used by your body just to survive so
they don't make you strong and then when
you start eating enough to survive the
next calorie stop giving you strength so
that's when you can start working out or
you can work so someone who is very poor
like pack so lean may not have enough to
eat to be very productive but if you if
you could eat more than it would become
productive
so at the heart of it is this idea of
what they call a capacity curve in a
capacity curve as something like this
shape it relates how much effort you can
exercise - how much you how much income
you have and of course how much income
you have is supposed to be related to
how much you consume so what is the
assumption that is underlying the the
fact that I have put income here on the
x-axis so for example the simplest case
would be all you have you eat of course
we know that it's not - because you also
need to take care of your basic needs we
need to close yourself you need to pay
your children school fee maybe you need
something for your housing so maybe you
will eat you will only consume a part of
your income but maybe some fraction of
what you have you are going to you're
going to eat so that creates a
relationship between the income you have
today and how much you get to it right
so instead of income here we could have
calories consumed and one first big
question that we'll have to answer next
time is how steep is this relationship
between how much income people have and
how much they are eating right but here
we are assuming that is some
relationship and it won't be cheap
enough so whenever you have income you
start eating and so why is the waste and
what we have here on the on the left is
on the x-axis in the work capacity so
how much of how many bushels of wheat
are you able to harvest or something
like that how much how many how many
times how many times can you dig so the
work capacity you think of it as
physical output but of course there
could be a relationship between this
physical output and you and your income
tomorrow because for example you could
be paid by the
this so if you paid by the piece how
about many bushel of wheat you harvest
you get that much income that creates
the work capacity and your income
tomorrow related one for one right so
here we have income today work capacity
and instantly we could have income today
and income tomorrow ok now why the shape
there the way it is what does the shape
what does the ship represent
exactly the left part is the first part
where you are just getting enough to
survive so you are just getting your you
are just eating enough to survive so the
first few calories are good because they
keep you alive so you can actually move
about but after that it just keeps you
at this kind of low level right and then
you start having maybe 1,200 1,500
calories and then suddenly you you know
is your with a good breakfast you're
eating before going out for you run the
it shoots up and then why doesn't
flatten out again if we had continued
the curve what would happen I really go
down you think of Thanksgiving
post-thanksgiving slump actually
probably gets a big down going so that
crease is kind of funny shape between
between euro ha income today a new work
capacity and therefore between your
income today and income tomorrow
oh it could be you know within a week or
something like that right which seems to
have a reasonable BioDigital sense now
what happened when when the price of
when the price of food went up what does
it do to the work capacity yeah
[Music]
exactly so what happened when the what
happens when the price of food goes up
is that for each a fraud that you for
each in terms of bushel of wits that's
the same thing but in terms of actual
income that the the bushel of wheat
transformed into how much income that
creates that that creates a jump down
because now for any to create so it's to
go from income to to work capacity to
crave form from income today to cannery
that's more expensive so the curve
shifts down because for every dollar
that you spend on hoop here that you
spend on food the that's fewer calories
and therefore that shifts down whatever
you are you are able to achieve in terms
of capacity right so if we have if we
have it in the form of income to work
capacity the prices of food going down
going up so it makes the curve going
down yeah
here we are if we're thinking of Paxson
we are thinking about physical time but
if we're thinking about packs audience
children for example it could well be
their capacity to focus in class and I
could easily add the same shape in fact
they are also seeing that completes also
for calories for children for example
was another intestinal worms and
intestinal worms sort of also shift your
work capacity your attention cable sit
down because they are eating your food
there for you that that tends to make
the kids anemic and less likely to be
listening that's exactly right
how would you call it
west-southwest right it has both a shift
and a scratch which is it will take more
it will take more it will take ma of
your income today to have you switch to
the you think of it going this way and
alternatively what happens when the when
the wages go down that's another thing
we can we can look at what happens to
the work capacity not to the work
capacity but if we put if we put income
under on the y-axis now income to more
on the y-axis and the wages go down it
again will do the same thing because now
this the same work capacity will
translate into less income so what was
happening in Indonesia in 2008 it on a
one hand food was food prices were going
up on the other hand farmers were
stressed out because the prices were the
input prices were going up so at the
same time they wanted to reduce the
wages when the prices were increasing
both of these phenomenal crazies like
Southwest shift in the work in the
capacity oh yeah
that's an excellent question so why
didn't quite the farmer just increase
the prices the thing is that with the
agricultural cycle you produce and then
so you put your seat you put your
fertilizer in the ground and you put
your crop in the ground and then you
wait around and the cop comes in and you
try to sell it and you're exactly right
that the the fact that the input prices
have gone up while the domain in
principle would not have gone up would
have meant that the food price is
probably the the food price is sold by
the farmer would probably go up but what
happened is that they weren't very sure
whether or not the food prices we are
going to go up by the time they sold
their food in proportion to the input
prices so what the situation that
prevailed in 2008 is a lot of volatility
which is not the prices were high but
they were also increasing and that was
true for the input prices and I were -
for the output prices and when you were
talking to the farmer everybody felt
that they were holding the short end of
the stick
the farmer who have saying well yes the
food prices would increase but we don't
know whether we will increase enough to
cover output prices our input prices
however the farmers found it difficult
to get loans for example so even if they
know that the prices are going to go up
for their input in the future in the
meantime they still had to buy the
fertilizer so they sort of had to cut
cost now so this is a little bit what
was happening is the mismatch between
the fact you have to pay for the
fertilizer today and you're going to
realize the output in the future so that
creates uncertainty plus the fact that
you need to finance it one way or the
other which is why add at that time
there was this kind of two things going
on which were both going on against the
poor guy so this is what we have with
the with the capacity Co now what does
the so this we've made this reasoning in
the form of we've had this reasoning for
food but let's think a bit about other
reasons other forget
we're talking about work physical work
capacity think about other reason why
there might be a relationship between
your income today and an income at some
point in the future think of it the next
generation think of it next month or
anything like that can you think of
other reasons why this kind of funnily
shaped curve might appear so weave weave
so food might be one what would be other
reasons why this funnel shape curve
might appear yeah so let's go to the
education one how why do you think
[Music]
yeah
so this is right that there is probably
a relationship between how long you can
keep the kid in school say because if
there are school fees you might have
might not be able to afford them or they
might also be an opportunity cost for
the child to be in school like the
piling son couldn't afford to be in
school because he had to work so that
creates I think it's not very
controversial to say there might be a
relationship between your income today
and how long your kid will stay in
school and then there is probably a
relationship between how long your kids
can stay in school and their income
which will create a relationship between
your income today and the income of the
child so that creates a relationship of
a form of another but why what would be
necessary for this relationship to of
this S shape so what you have explained
I think and I I think most people would
agree though we can ask around but I
think what you have explained clearly is
that we might expect to education a
relationship between income today and
income of the children now what else do
you need for that relationship to of
this funny-shaped
yeah suddenly going to be editing
usually needs to drop in income compared
to having gone to a to a masters
especially if you choose the Masters
properly but this is exactly that which
is we need one more thing what you're
saying is exactly right what's your name
you need one more thing we also need for
the benefits of the first few years of
education to be relatively low so and
that's an empirical question that goes
back to the plausibility question that
you were asking earlier is either the
case that the first few years of
education are useless or not very useful
or is it the case that every year of
Education is a year of education and
there will be an s-shaped based on
education if that's if the first three
years of education are not that useful
and they won't be if in fact even the
first few year of education are that
useful I'm not going to answer this
question now but we are going to answer
it in course in due course whether or
not this is the case you see that this
is not something that we can just think
of it in the abstract we sort of have to
find out there could be reasons the
other way you could feel for example
that the first year of education is
amazingly useful because this is when
you learn to read and once you know how
to read who cares about all of these
things that I'm trying to teach you
because you can teach yourself
everything you need to know or you could
think that education is not useful
unless you have a secondary degree
because that's what opens the door to
you for various formal jobs right it
could easily cut one way or the other I
don't know if you guys have an insight
for example what is your view that this
that is that this is likely to be that
the first few years of education are not
so useful
so you think that in the first years a
few years of education are very useful
so there would be a relationship between
income today and income of my children
but it wouldn't have this shape if that
is the case in fact it might have a
completely opposite shape where it's
it's more like an inverted L as opposed
to an S so education would be one what
would be another possibility for this
for this funny-looking
shape to appear between income today and
income at some point in the future is on
my income in the future or the income of
my children know my income next year
what would be other sources of such
shapes
alright so for example so access to the
access to the to the job market for
example it is possible if I can rephrase
what you are saying that people people
who live in a village there or isin is
the village where they are going
whatever they're going stuff and they
are making some income but they don't
have the perspective in mind that they
could go to the city where number of
other jobs are available
so in that case for people who are very
little money and live in a village well
well their children will again have also
live in the village of and have very
little money if suddenly something opens
the possibility to to go to the city for
examples someone comes into some money
gets gets the option to to buy a train
ticket goes to the city and figure out
the options there then suddenly you can
you can you have access to a number of
other opportunity potentially much more
rewarding that would create that would
potentially create this a ship where the
fact of being poor means that you live
in a relatively restricted environment
you stay there and then when you become
when you become just a bit richer that
opens the opens this opportunity that
makes help you that help you become much
richer that's a very nice example yeah
right so singing is a very interesting
example so saving again you could say
well if you suppose for example that
people saved some fixed fraction of
their income then if I have more income
today I will save more therefore I will
inverse more therefore I will be richer
in the future now if it was a fixed
fraction of my income again would I have
an S would have less I would necessarily
see a relationship between income today
and income tomorrow just because I save
more but it's a fixed if it's a fixed
fraction fraction of my income what else
do I need for this S shape to to come
yes
[Music]
today
for an s-shape to appear due to savings
is that actually people do not save a
fixed fraction of their income is that
for some reason the proof save less than
the rich so that would create so if
that's the case and we are going to
let's talk a bit let's talk to whether
we have reasons to think that the poor
would save more less than the rich but
let's first take it as given for a
moment and say let's assume the poor
save less than the rich then if that's
the case that might also create for
example assume the poor save nothing
then if you're very pro you have no
income tomorrow coming out of
investments and then when if you start
saving when you become a little richer
and that one is invested that starts
creating some return for that money and
you get into the steeper part of the
Earthship so that's a first mechanism to
which savings could create a
relationship between your income today
and your income - model would have this
S shape now what we do have to explain
is why did the case that the poor would
be able to save less than the rich that
is something that I think we all have in
mind say yes of course the poor don't
save because they have no money but one
thing I would you to want you to keep in
mind is that the poor have no money but
they have a present and they have a
future so unless they think that they
will have more money tomorrow or unless
for some reason they are extremely
impatient then the poor should want to
save as well because of course today
they have very little money for food but
tomorrow they'll have very little for
food as well so we need to go a little
further than to say well of course the
poor save because they have no money
right again let's not go into the
details of that I think there are good
reasons to think that the probe would be
less able to save than the rich and
we're going to go to it when to have a
whole set of lectures about that but
just keep in mind that it's not so
obvious that the poor would be less
likely to save another so you wanted to
do
let's finish taping and then we'll good
I'll go back to you for help another
reason why there might be a relationship
between income today and income tomorrow
of this from due to savings even if the
if the poor save are exactly as much as
suppose the deep wonders and the rich
save was a proportion of the income that
could still be a relationship like that
yeah better investment opportunity for
example it could be that the bank is
just not interested in a very small
saving accounts and in fact it's the
case that the banks are not interested
in very small saving accounts because as
soon as you your bank and you take the
saving of someone the government is on
your back to make sure that you don't
run away with the saving which is a good
idea but that cost money so maintaining
a saving account for someone costs some
amount of money and god godless of the
size of the account still costs the same
money because you need to do all the
paperwork so as a result if you come to
a bank with your five rupees the bank is
going to say thank you but I don't want
your five rupees you whereas if you come
with your five thousand rupees sure I'm
going to put it in this like very nice I
can't for you with a nice return so
that's one reason right there that the
poor might have to save under the
mattress where their money might
disappear where it might be stolen and
so the return on saving for the poor
might be very low it might even be
negative
once the return for the rich might be
richer might be higher either because
they are access to this savings account
or they can for example start a small
business for example when you want to
start a small business is it worthwhile
starting a tiny business with almost
nothing maybe not maybe it needs to be
large enough for it to be to be
worthwhile so even if the corner which
were to save the same amount
proportionally there might still be
something related not to the how much
they save but what's the productivity of
those savings
you were talking about healthcare why
don't you tell us what you're thinking
what healthcare
you can start fighting with us into
buying no health care and maybe towards
the end we have higher income at level
up because you an account you know each
other that help problem that you might
have low incomes and that personally
if you're very poor you might not be
able to purchase very simple but I'm
relatively cheap technologies that
prevent you from getting sick it could
be a chlorine for your water it could be
a water filter it could be a bad net to
put on top of your kids when they slip
so that they don't get malaria so all of
these things might might hold me like
some fixed investment that if you can't
afford them you can't afford them and
then you getting Sigma therefore you're
less productive therefore you make less
money etc so that is another that's
another source of potential where we
would have this s-shaped again because
then we again have to think about these
goods are things that are a little bit
lumpy like a bed net for example our
water filter that you can either afford
another phone so if you have enough
money you afford it and then you can be
generally healthier or don't lose all
your calories to diarrhea and other nice
things like that and if you're poor you
you will be sick all the time of paying
for the doctors for example so for
example if someone is sick and and very
poor they might not be able to pay for
the doctor or then they stay sick so
they can't earn money and again the
doctor is probably a doctor visit is
like one fix lumpy investment which you
may or may not be able to afford that
would be another source of an s-shape
like that so the reason why I went to
all of these examples is that we are
going to have a lot to say about the
exact story that paxil in told me about
the food whether this was a real story
in this case or whether it's some story
that he was telling himself to make him
to explain the situation he was in but
really he there was something else
behind these problems like his
depression or something like that
but the first time it was formalized
while was in this ID in this context of
nutrition and it's very natural to think
of it in the context of nutrition but it
could apply
I and a very important part of the
discussion that I want you to keep in
mind is that it's not enough for there
to be a relationship between income
today and income tomorrow to create a
poverty trap it needs to have this funny
shape and I want to to discuss why so
the way we are going to think of it is
we are going to think about what how do
I go what is the dynamic of someone's
income over time so let's start with
let's start with with this picture which
brings inherited income on the x-axis to
think of it as income today and income
from work what I have plotted here is
this s-shaped curve think of it for
example as coming from nutrition but any
of the examples that you talked about if
you don't like the nutrition one and the
line that goes to the diagonal is the
45-degree line
so why is the 45 degree line relevant
and interesting here is that on the
45-degree line income today is income is
the same as income tomorrow right so we
are going to make use of it now I want
to say to try and look at the dynamic of
someone's incomes over time so suppose
someone god is a little income y prime 0
oh where do I read their income entired
1
yeah
exactly so to get to go from income yi0
to y1 I go on the vertical line up to
the curve that tell me this is what
someone who was who can who stopped his
life with some income yi0 can make this
decision about how much to eat create
some calories create some work capacity
goes to work generate an income that he
takes home that's the income that we
have on the curvy line and then I want
to say well that becomes y1 right and
then y1 is going to become the YY the y
0 of tomorrow so to find it I'm doing
exactly what you are saying which is I'm
going horizontally to the 45-degree line
because now and I could go down again so
from Y of 0 I go to y1 then always on
tally on the 45-degree line gives me Y 1
again and then how do I find y2 I go
vertical again that gives me Y 2 again I
go always on tile again to the 45-degree
line and I continue like that and where
will I end up at the I will end up at
the intersection of the 45-degree line
and a shaped curve right at the first
intersection now
what if I start with the higher-income
if I start with the income y y0 double
prime i go vertical to the curve that
gives me y 1 double prime I have to go
originally to find it on the when it
becomes income tomorrow again you have
to connect cetera and I again end up at
the at the intersection of the 45-degree
line and a shape curve but now it's a
higher intersection now what happen if I
start at the at the point at the seek
point in the middle over there
which way will that go that will go down
if I go as a sick point I go vertical
then left then down so after which point
two ago what is the key point after
which I will start going going to the
high high point yeah so the intersection
from below so at this point k when we
integrate the 45-degree line where the
capacity curve intersects the 45-degree
line from below anything to the right go
to the high steady-state anything to the
left go to the low steady state so this
is if you want what this possibility
that there are two steady-state
depending on where you start from is
what the formalization of a poverty trap
which is anybody who is poorer than the
unstable equilibrium over there the
intersection between the S shape the
place where the S shape no one if
someone starts with exactly this income
where do they go
if someone start with exactly the
intersection of the 45-degree line and
the S shaped curve do they go down or do
they go up they just stay there so it is
also a steady state but it's a very
unstable one if anything happens any
small perturbation it goes slightly to
the left they go all the way down if
they go slightly to the right they go
all the way up so we call that an
unstable steady state so there is one
unstable steady state and two stable
ones and those two stable ones is what
we are talking about that there could be
a poverty table yes
can someone explain that why are we why
do we go you want to know why we are
going always on tile to the 4045 degree
light yeah can someone explain that once
and then I really need as well
[Music]
exactly what I am trying to find out so
the reason why we are using the
horizontal line is that so from y 0 I
know that I go to y1 and then I want to
know well from y1 where will I go
so for that I need to put Y 1 on the
x-axis and the 45-degree line allows me
to do that because the 45-degree line is
where the vertical is equal to the
horizontal so I'm going right to find y1
on the original line which helps me to
find it on the x-axis and then I know
that from y1 I go to Y 2 and then I get
always on tile and then I get vertical
and then I can always enter that makes
sense
is it clear for everybody this is it
would be better if we were all on the
same place that we that we have that
here this is not that this is not
obvious it's not meant to be obvious
just to
so let's take a pass seeker
like that's your y0 is what you start
from and then the curves gives us what
is the relationship between income today
and income tomorrow so think of it for
is with the food example you start with
some income you eat it you decide how
much to eat let's say you eat 80% of it
you eat it
that gives you some strength you go work
that gives you some wage that's your
income from work you understand step
here right
y0 goes to I won for the first vertical
step and then we are looking for y1 on
your is under so we have y1 on the
vertical axis but now we need to find a
way to put it back on the original axis
and the 45-degree line helps us to do
that because on the 45-degree line the
vertical distance is the same as the
horizontal distance so the horizontal
line is just a click to help us find
where is y 1 on the horizontal axis
which helps us go - why - that makes
sense
so from y 0 to y 1 vertically that's
just the capacity curve then the
horizontal line is just to tell us what
does it now what is the new y 0 the new
y 0 is y 1 and then again we go
vertically - why - always on tally to
find it on the horizontal axis
vertically Exeter
do you need some is whatever we whatever
missing is the right unit of time
depending of the problem we are looking
at so for example if it's food that
might be the day if it's the income of
your children that might be a generation
in some sense once we have decided what
the problem we were looking at the unit
of time it doesn't really matter we are
just to it whether or not you into
you're going to stay here whether things
tend to bring you back here or since
them to pull you away from it think of
it for example as as magnets either they
are they cling together or they are
trying to go away or think of it as a
stick does it stay vertical or does it
fall down so here you think
suppose that we start with income and
the first income we were getting his
white three that's going to pull you you
know you're going to go vertical a
little bit horizontal a little bit
exactly R that's going to pull you
exactly at that first steady state right
so if you start so now if if you start
from the [ __ ] steady state and something
slightly pushes you away from it it's
going to bring you back to it if it
you're a little bit richer than the
first steady state you're going to again
go back to the rock steady state if
you're slightly richer it's pulling you
down if you're flatly Pula poor it's
pulling you up and now if you're looking
at the one that's here on top that's the
same thing at the very top if you're
slightly poorer it's pulling you up
towards it if you're slightly richer
it's pulling you down towards it now if
you look at the one that well the line
intersects from below if you're exactly
at it you stare at it but if you're
slightly poorer where do you go
all the way
if you start give it sir all the way up
so that one is not stable so basically
you follow your arrow wherever they are
going to take you okay any more question
yeah
income today versus income tomorrow our
income that you inherited versus in
person income that you create yourself
whatever skills we are talking about so
for example it could be the income you
start with yes in the food example it
would be the income you had at the end
of today and then that would be
inherited income you inherited it from
yesterday and then the income from work
would be the income at the end of the
day
so here the scale would be one day in
the skin the education example it would
go from you income to what your children
will make that's a whole generation so
the time scale it depends on the on the
problem I think in the food example it's
useful to think of a day in the health
example it might be you first you go
from whatever you start with to to the
curve and then the carries right
the curve is trying to go back to the
45-degree line so the closer you are to
the intersection the less you move which
is why this is everything pulls you back
they're not only intersection notes the
stable ones they want to the left and
they want to the right not the middle
one which you have a tendency to go away
from and here's a question on this on
how this works
nabob whose name I don't know asked
earlier which is what is actually the
shape of the what is actually the shape
of the of the curve and that's a key
question that's going back to the
questions we were asking and in the case
of Education for example is the
relationship between income today and
income tomorrow is due to education is
it really of this shape or is it of
another shape that's what we have to
assert empirically and it's going to
have to be gathered on a case by case
example so for example for food to
create this shape what we are going to
create to know what is the form of the
ship we are going to need to know two
things we need to know how much what is
the relationship between how much income
you have and how many calories you
consume and what is the relationship
between the calorie you consume and your
work capacity and the product of the two
will be that curve and the shape it has
God knows I mean actually even we know
but I'm going to we're going to cover
that next next time so this is this is
assuming that the capacity of indeed
else is shaped and we can see how the
poverty trap can emerge now if instead
the capacity curve had this ship which
is for example think of your example of
Education and think that in fact the
first few years of education are very
valuable and the next years you guys are
kind of wasting your time not to speak
of me and the next years of education
are not so valuable what is really
important is to learn how to read
imagine that that's the case then it
means that the relationship between
income today and income tomorrow is not
a ship anymore its first very high and
then it tapers off and so we can play
the same game again that we were playing
before we can say well let's have let's
update let's do all the diagonal
let's start with some income a 1 to find
out income tomorrow what do we do we go
vertical we find income a 2 then we have
to go
always on tile to the 45-degree line to
find it on the origin tile line we go
vertical again to find it on the on the
curve horizontal again work together
again where do we end up Q now suppose
we had started above Q where would we
end up Q suppose we had started anywhere
in between where would we end up Q so
there is no poverty type in this case if
there is only one intersection because
the the return our first high and then
low then they won't be a poverty trap it
doesn't mean that there is no
relationship between income today and
income tomorrow is one but the point is
that that relationship is first deep and
then tapers off so for example imagine
that you the only type of businesses
that you can run our businesses that you
can run yourself that for some reason
you are in a in a business where you
can't really have employees imagine so
in that case your first investment will
be quite valuable right but then
eventually you can't really add much
more because you won't have enough time
to sell all of these things so the the
income will first go your first dollars
invested will have a very high return
and then less and less and less and less
and so in that case everybody will end
up at the same place an example that
that makes it that could make it clear
for example is going back to a Kenyan
farmer from the MTV Video Kennedy
fertilizer if you put fertilizer on your
cup well when you put just a little bit
the effect are very high but when you
start putting more eventually the soil
contacts orbit so the effect are less
and less and less high so we could
imagine that and even if you don't have
a
enough to put on your entire field to
start with you could imagine that you
would first put it in the most
productive part of your field so the
first unit of fertilizer you're putting
is very high return the second you need
a little less because you're going to
the place of your field that is less
productive anyway and the third unit
even less the first one is really not
that productive because now you end up
putting more where you started from in
the first place so that's not really
helpful anymore so in that case the the
return don't have this earth shape they
have this in rattle l inverted l-shape
so in that case there is no poverty
table and so there is where the question
that you were asking is essential which
is how do we know what the shape of this
curve because the shape of this curve is
going to crucially determine whether or
not we have a trap or not and what I
want you to remember is that that's more
than there is a relationship between
income today and income to move it has
to be this relationship of this shape my
other so that's a frock thing which is
if the relationship is inverted l-shape
like that which is the cannoneer I can
okay canonical case in economics most of
our economic model what you learn in
1401
have production function of this form
where what this is a production function
which we called have decreasing returns
where the first unit invested is very
profitable then it becomes less and less
profitable we've already discussed a
number of cases numbers reasons why the
returns might not always be decreasing
for example we discussed the case of
calories well the first they might be an
increasing zone and then a decreasing
zone we discuss education might or might
not be that way
we got an example interesting example
about businesses where you might not
have a very profitable opportunity for
your business when you first when if you
don't have enough money we discussed
savings which may or may not have this
of this form where nobody wants your
small savings so there are reasons why
it's not why it may not always be
inverted l-shape but if it is inverted
l-shape they won't be a profit at this
is a confusion that you might be very
bored with me repeating the same thing
for the fifth times now
the reason were n sister this is a
confusion that we hear over and over
again among policy makers in the policy
discourse whenever they are thinking of
a double feedback loop for example kids
who have less education make less money
and parents who have less money send
their kids less to school immediately
people think huh if there is a double
feedback loop like that that creates a
poverty table and the point is that
that's not sufficient that's necessary
but that's not sufficient because if the
devil feedback loop gives you a nice
inverted l-shaped eventually everybody
will end up nicely in the same place
okay so there's more which is here is
another case where we have an s-shaped
curve but the s-shaped curve is not in
terms it is a little different it's a
little higher so why would it be a
little higher for example what why has
it moved up compared to what we had
before
going back to Stacey go back to the food
example for reason that you know maybe
the government came and built some
irrigation dams and the productivity of
land has gone up so to produce the same
amount of food you need less effort so
they the work capacity translate into a
higher income from work so for whatever
reason the curve sheets up so then what
happened
we start from someone we give some some
person some income y 0 we find y 1 by
going vertical find it again owes on the
horizontal line y 1 going back to Y 2
horizontal again where do we end up at
the intersection and now there is only
one intersection so wherever we start
with we are going to end up at the same
intersection so in that case is there
going to be a poverty trap no in that
case there is no poverty trap because
again there is one steady-state so an
s-shape is not even a sufficient
condition for a poverty trap it is
necessary but it's not sufficient right
let's find another example which is this
one where in fact people now it's the
opposite there was some flood and the
land is now completely washed out so
people are very in productive they have
to work very hard to produce very little
so what happened to my poor has shaped
it's shifted to the southwest right so
now if I start from if I start from from
y0 quite high where do I go
so I go up but then it's not enough so
the 45-degree line is to the left I have
to go left down again down again down
again and again I'm going to end up at
the single intersection that there is
where I'm always pulled up which is a
very low income so in a sense there is
no poverty trap here either because it's
not that if you're poor you stay poor
and if you're rich you stay rich
regardless you're going to be poor so
well you could think it's a universal
poverty trap or everything that's just
the way it is because if you think of if
you know if you ignore if you ignore the
right side we almost are in the inverted
l-shape except there are stuff that are
little bit irrelevant to the right the
reason why they are irrelevant is that
eventually everybody is becoming true
anyway so again we don't have poverty
top so let's look at those three an
example that's an example with a poverty
trap that's an example that doesn't have
one that's another example that doesn't
have one what is different between the
one example with a poverty trap and the
one which doesn't have one
the two yes can you tell me your name
exactly and well twice three times it
causes the 45-degree line one home video
so the the hole is that you're going to
have a poverty trap if the capacity
curve or whatever is the curve between
the income from work and inherited
income crosses the 45 degree line at
least one from below this is that is
there is at least one unstable
equilibrium you're crossing from below
and that is necessary for having a
poverty trap so you so what you need in
other one is to have a zone where income
is accelerating and this zone must be at
a place where the income was relatively
low to start with and it needs to
accelerate enough that it's becoming
high to start with in other words the
needs to be a zone where if you're below
this dune
you're making less to mold and you
started from today and when you're on
the right of this zone you're making
more to mold and you started from today
and you need to have this point
otherwise there is no poverty table all
right so that's the mathematical
expression of it and now in a sense the
the game that we are going to play all
over this class is to be looking for is
there a way in this situation where
whatever is the relationship between
income today and income tomorrow causes
the 45-degree line from below are we not
in this situation and now we are in a
much better position to ask the question
that Zach asked at the beginning of the
question which is are we really
believing that there could be a poverty
trap based on food I didn't want to
answer his question to start with
because I needed some time to specify
the question in a much more precise way
which is now we can only ask the
question say is it really possible that
the relationship between the calories I
consume and my strength as this specific
form where it intersect the 45-degree
line from below and how does that
intersect with the fact that I tunes how
much to consume because of course if
people if they were if there is indeed a
strong relationship between work
capacity between the calories consumed
and the work capacity then people should
try and get out of it by eating as much
as possible when they are very poor so
to the extent that people can choose how
much to consume how much food to eat
they should eat more when they are very
poor in order to try and pull themselves
to the right of this point and when they
are richer than it wouldn't really
matter so they would they would they
would they would eat less so that would
that would create a force that goes
against an S shape for the capacity
curve so we have to we have to see and
that goes back to your question where do
you get it from where we get it from for
looking at the data and looking at house
to what extent people who have more
money it's so much more and to what
extent people who eat so much more are
so much more productive and that's what
we are going to do we are going to do it
for food but now that we understood the
principle for food we are going to do it
for food we are going to do it for
education we are going to do it for
health we are going to do for savings
for businesses etc
right so one so that's a very good
question what we can try now is to try
and reinterpret mr. Celine story in the
context of this and you could say well
perhaps s exactly it was exactly
something like that perhaps he was it
was maybe even so what would have
happened to him let's see I want to
what would have happened to him so we
discussed that one thing that might have
happened to him is that something
happened to the capacity curve right we
were saying that the coincident increase
in the wage so I decrease in the wage
and increase in the food prices means
that the capacity of tend to move to the
southwest so I assumed that pack Saleem
was at the hike William up there
right but right there and then the curve
moves slightly to the right then he
might suddenly of going down you know
then with the same income he certainly
is now below what would correspond to
the new equilibrium and it would start
falling down down down down and once he
start going down there is no going up
again it could also have eliminated we
more we might also be in a situation
where at the beginning there was just
one equilibrium so we were for example
in this situation and then once the
curve moves down they are now they are
now two equilibria including a +10
stable one so we may have starting from
a situation where people were productive
enough that they were always moving up
and then with the increase in in food
prices and the decrease in waitress that
curve shifts down and now it creates two
equilibria so some people get trapped
like he was what was interesting in
paxil in villages is that in the same
villages I met people who were happily
eating enough so they seemed that there
was both kinds which seems to make you
think that there was these two these two
things were coexisting
so maybe what happened with him is that
we started from a situation like that
and then we moved left left and we end
up with this diaper situation that's
possible
so what we hadn't need in this actually
video is a lots of other we we said when
we just started the started the class is
lots of example of operatic hub an in
each cases we could I don't think well
what makes us think that they're
reasonably the poverty type in this case
of what makes us think that maybe there
is no poverty table in this case so one
example is what happened with the with
the farmer the farmer that they meet in
what case so they claim that there was a
property table so what is the implicit
argument that they had in mind that
would help us think that for a farmer
the decision to use fertilizer if this
is correspond to that problem versus
correspond to that problem what what do
we need to know about fertilizer and
fertilizer use to iron sort out whether
we are in the situation that they talk
about or in the other situation yeah
right so you would be that guy for you
but why would it be why do you have him
why would there be a minimum fertilizer
you sold by the bag of 50 kg so in that
case what we have is not so much a shape
but something which is degenerated s
where we have you get nothing if you
can't invest enough and then you get the
return which are potentially very steep
at the beginning so what we could have
is that instead of a nice little curvy s
we have a flat part and then L inverted
L but if we have a flat part and then
inverted L it would still work like an S
because they would still be an
intersection where the curve intersects
from above on the flat part in
intersection where in intersects from
from from below at the beginning of the
L shape and an other intersection where
intersect from above at the end of the L
shape so the S doesn't have to be a
proper s it could be a flat part and
inverted L so this this example could be
one which is you can only buy fertilizer
by the 50kg
what other situation could be we could
we could find yeah
so
[Music]
so that would be so that would be a
possibility if the chance of success
depends on how much you use I think it's
not very likely that it would be a
purely physical thing because first
catalyser is quite scalable but one way
in which we could have your stories if
it requires to learn to use fertilizer
it requires some learning so and there
is no point doing all that learning you
know when asking all of your neighbor
how they do it and try to understand how
they do it
maybe experiment a little bit maybe it
won't work fast maybe there is no point
to go through all of this learning if at
the end of the day you know that you
will no matter what you will always be
able to use just a little bit so that
would be one way in which you would
again create this like you're not going
to use any fertilizer if you know that
you eventually would be able to use it
on a substantial part of your field yep
the fact is if you have like a little
bit of fertilizer appointments they're
single you can't really you know why
couldn't they invest so say
start off
possibility is that if you invest just a
little bit let's say oxidizer scales
nicely so even if you invest you can
invest just a little bit and you can do
it but then you're going to make just a
little bit more money and then we need
some other mechanism which means that
saving a little bit more money is not
silly better people are not going to do
it so then we need to bring in something
else which is along the line of what we
were discussing earlier in the class we
need to bring in something else which is
the banks are not going to take your
small amount of money oh you know if you
have small amount of money you're going
to waste it but if you have a lot you
you know that now that's enough money to
be worthwhile and you're going to keep
it all right so I we are going to end
here for today so make sure you
understand this because we are not
willing to go back to it formally a lot
but this is going to be with us all the
time
and on Tuesday we're going to go to
experiment